من مستشفى ناصر في خانيونس ينضم الينا
مراسل الجزيره مؤمن اشرافي مؤمن في الساعه
الماضيه تابعنا واياك عمليات القصف
والغارات في محيط المستشفى مباشره على
الهواء مع استمرار
توافد الشهداء والجرحى الى المستشفى الان
كيف يبدو الوضع
عندك نعم حسن الوضع على حاله تماما كما
كنا في اخر رساله على الهواء مباشره القصف
المدفعي لازال متواصلا في محيط مجمع ناصر
كما ان
اشتباكات عنيفه تدور في محيط المستشفى
تحديدا في المنطقه الجنوبيه وايضا في
المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه خان يونس بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الاليات المتمركزه في منطقه
مقبره الحي النمساوي تطلق قذائفها
الصاروخيه بين الفين والاخرى وايضا تطلق
تقوم باطلاق نار كثيف يبدو بعد بعد
استهدافها من قبل مقاومين فلسطينيين وايضا
في المنطقه الغربيه التي توغلت اليها قوات
الاحتلال تشهد اشتباكات ضاريه بين
المقاومه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعمده
الخان لازالت تتصاعد من المنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه من مدينه خانيونس وسط تحليق مكثف
لمقاتلات حربيه اسرائيليه ويبدو ان هذه
الاعم الدخان ناجمه عن غارات وقصف
اسرائيلي استهدف منشات معينه في
تلك المنطقه هذه المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه
هي معروفه بانها توجد فيها العديد من
المصانع ومخازن للاخشاب وايضا منشات
صناعيه وتجاريه اخرى بالاضافه الى مناطق
سكنيه في هذا المحور الذي يشهد هو ايضا
محيطه اشتباكات بين المقاومه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيل في منطقه محيط منطقه
الكتيبه وشارع خمسه وشارع القسام وايضا في
محيط منطقه البلد وسط مدينه خانيونس عدد
الشهداء حتى هذه اللحظه وصل الى 60 شهيد
في الذين وصلوا الى مجمع ناصر نتيجه تواصل
القصف والغارات الاسرائيليه على مختلف
المناطق في مدينه خانيونس الى جانب مئات
الجرحى وايضا هناك العشرات من جثامين
الشهداء في مناطق يصعب على سياره الاسعاف
او حتى المواطنين الوصول اليها لانتشال
جثامينهم وايضا اجلاء العائلات المحاصره
سواء داخل مراكز ايواء او في منازل تتعرض
للقصف من قبل المدفعيه والاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه لدينا سيده جاءت من محيط
مستشفى الخير في
غرب مدينه خان يونس هذه السيده فقدت
اولادها لا تعرف مصيرهم حتى هذه اللحظه
تحدثنا عن روايه روايتك شو صار معكم خش
اليهود الساعه 9 في الليل
علينا طحم المستشفى ظلهم يطخطخ علينا
يطخطخ حوالين المستشفى ويرموا صواريخ وفي
عماره عاليه جنب المستشفى في الطابق
السابع قصفها وضربوا منها قتلوا منها
شهداء وفي واحد منهم يعني جسه مولعه بعدين
طلعنا على مستشفه الخير تبينا جواها فظلم
يخشوا اليهود صاروا تخ تخوا اليهود يخشوا
ويرموا علينا قنابل قنابل اللي هي ارتجاج
في في المخ وقنص بعدين يرموا علينا زي
قنابل الغاز فاحنا هلقيت خلص يعني
المستشفى راحت وضلوا يقصفوا في المستشفى
واخذوا الرجال شلحه يعني واخذوهم اخذوا
الاطباء وحن النسوان في قنص و قاعدين يقنص
عليه يعني اخذت طلقه في ظهري وفي رجلي وفي
ناس عائلات ثانيه اللي اخذ في صدره اللي
اخذ في راسه اللي زلم عجوز في رجله تصاوب
والثاني في ايده والمره الثانيه يعني في
رجلها فانا بناشد انا اولادي انا لهلق ما
طلعونا اليهود طلعوا ع عشره من النساء
فذهبنا الى مستشفه
الاقصى جامعه الاقصى لتحت ف هلقيت اجا
زلمه اخذ مني اودي فقالي هلقيت ل شافني
كلي دم فقال لي يا اختي من هال الصبح ان
شاء الله بجيبلك اسعاف يجي بياخذك هلقيت
اج الاسعاف اخذناه لقيت انا في ناس اخذت
اولادي مش عارفه وين انا اولادي انا في
مجمع ناصر بس انا مش عارفه وين الاولاد
راحوا فانا بناشد يلي بشفهم يعرفهم منظار
حسنين هذول يلي شافهم يتواصل معاي ويحكي
لي عليهم ايش بدي اسوي بس حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل
فيهم نعم حسن هذه عينه صغيره من شهادات
لمواطنين حاله ماسويه فق الام هنا زوجها
اعتقله جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اولادها
وابنائها في منطقه اخرى لا تعرف مصيرهم
حتى هذه اللحظه تقطعت سبل التواصل
والاتصال بين الاهالي وذويهم سواء هنا في
مجمع ناصر او في المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه
خانيونس وايضا لا توجد امكانيات لا الهلال
الاحمر ولا الصليب الاحمر الوصول الى تلك
المنطقه ل الوصول الى عائلتها وايضا او
ايصالها الى ابنائها الذين بقوا لوحدهم
وهم جميعهم من الاطفال حسب ما افادتنا قبل
قليل شكرا لك مؤمن شرافي بالانتقال مباشره
الى رفح ايضا في